you can see the gut is it hiding the gut
do i breasts
we need you to make comedy because life
sucks right now
i am going to teach you about comedy how
to make it
direct it how to write it how to perform
it oh my god
sports i love them who are your favorite
teams
the orlando blooms
[Music]
people should look at comedies as dramas
when they're writing they should be
stories that would work just as well
without any jokes
well holiday improvising i'll yell out
things it's almost like i'm a third
actor
in the scene oh that feels far okay this
is gonna hurt a little bit that's okay
stop smiling
ask yourself a lot of questions because
usually that's where the humor is is
in your identity the more nervous i get
the more i smile
so stop smiling stop it
you know you're using those uh real life
moments as ingredients that are inspired
by
things that have happened in your life i
am you
and you are me and we
are making love to your wife and she is
us
and we we're making love you and me
okay people get
involved in comedy are upset about
something i think i spent a lot of my
childhood alone because people were
playing sports
i was picked last in gym class and it
made me
angry you know what is comedy it's
speaking your truth and
revealing your darkest deepest stuff
that for most people they would
keep him stories are about people who
are messed up
and need to figure out a way to grow
so you want [ __ ] up people
find the courage to tell a heartfelt
great story
to show how people try to grow how they
try to find
happiness and every once in a while
they pee with the boner
i'm jed apatow and this is my master
class
you